every season somebody else was coming
out one talk shop to talk shows three
structures there have been over a
hundred talk shows since we started but
every time I would feel like alright got
to step up our game got to step up our
game the way you step up your game is
not to worry about the other guy in any
situation because you can't control the
other guy you only have control over
yourself so it's like running a race the
energy that it takes to look back and
see where the other guys are takes
energy away from you and if they're too
close it scares you so that's what I
would say to my team all the time don't
waste your time in the race looking back
to see where the other guy is or what
the other guy is doing it's not about
the other guy it's about what can you do
you just need to run that race as hard
as you can you need to give it
everything you've got all the time for
yourself my grandmother was a maid
that's all she ever knew the only real
expectation she held for me was that I
would one day become a maid and in her
words have some good white folks meaning
people who would not speak negatively
about me who would allow me to take food
home who would be good to me that was my
grandmother's dream for me but I had
another dream for myself more than a
dream I had a belief for myself I
remember watching her hang out clothes
on a line one day and say to me you have
to watch me oppa Gayle cuz one day
you'll have to do this for yourself and
knowing inside myself that that was not
going to be my life don't know how I
knew it
other than that thing that we all have
intuition or an instinct that said no
this will not be my life I knew that I
will not be hanging clothes on a line in
a backyard in Mississippi so I was
either four or five years old and that
belief that that would not be my life is
what I held on to for the longest of
times I just no matter what the
that there was something bigger greater
more for me you just watched two amazing
clips from Oprah Winfrey take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]